there are two motives for reading a book
one that you enjoy it
the other
that you can boast about it
stupidity and unconscious bias often do
more damage than venality
language serves not only to express
thought
but to make possible thoughts which
could not exist without it
do not fear to be eccentric in opinion
for every opinion now accepted was once
eccentric
of all forms of caution
caution in love is perhaps the most
fatal to true happiness
the fundamental cause of the trouble is
that in the modern world
the stupid are cocksure
while the intelligent
are full of doubt
to fear love is to fear life
and those who fear life
are already three parts dead
i would never die for my beliefs because
i might be wrong
in all affairs it's a healthy thing now
and then
to hang a question mark on the things
you have long taken for granted
one of the symptoms of an approaching
nervous breakdown
is the belief that one's work is
terribly important
fear is the main source of superstition
and one of the main sources of cruelty
to conquer fear
is the beginning of wisdom
it is easy to fall in love
the hard part is finding someone to
catch you
it is the preoccupation with possessions
more than anything else
that prevents us from living freely and
nobly
collective fear stimulates herd instinct
and tends to produce ferocity towards
those who are not regarded as members of
the herd
no one gossips about other people's
secret virtues
it has been said that man is a rational
animal
all my life i have been searching for
evidence which could support this
the secret of happiness is to face the
fact that the world is horrible
horrible
horrible
the infliction of cruelty with a good
conscience
is a delight to moralists
that is why they invented hell
neither a man nor a crowd nor a nation
can be trusted to act humanely or to
think sanely under the influence of a
great fear
the whole problem with the world
is that fools and fanatics are always so
certain of themselves
and wise are people so full of doubts
everything is vague to a degree
you do not realize till you have tried
to make it precise
the greatest challenge to any thinker
is stating the problem in a way that
will allow a solution
anything you're good at contributes to
happiness
to be without some of the things you
want
is an indispensable part of happiness
[Music]
science is what you know
philosophy is what you don't know
sin
is geographical
what is wanted is not the will to
believe
but the will to find out
which is the exact opposite
remember your
humanity and forget the rest
dogmatism is the greatest of mental
obstacles to human happiness
man is a credulous animal
and must believe something
in the absence of good grounds for
belief he will be satisfied with bad
ones
life is nothing but a competition
to be the criminal rather than the
victim
a happy life must be to a great extent
a quiet life for it is only in an
atmosphere of quiet
that true joy can live
is there any knowledge in the world
which is so certain that no reasonable
man could doubt it
how much longer is the world willing to
endure this spectacle of wanton cruelty
nothing is so exhausting as indecision
and nothing is so futile
patriotism is the willingness to kill
and be killed
for trivial reasons
conquer the world by intelligence
and not merely by being slavishly
subdued by the terror that comes from it
boredom is therefore a vital problem for
the moralist
since at least half the sins of mankind
are caused by the fear of it
[Music]
it is a waste of energy to be angry with
a man who behaves badly
just as it is to be angry with a car
that won't go
a sense of duty is useful in work but
offensive in personal relations
people wish to be liked
not to be endured with patient
resignation
mathematics rightly viewed possesses not
only truth
but supreme beauty
one of the most powerful of all our
passions is the desire to be admired and
respected
whoever wishes to become a philosopher
must learn not to be frightened by
absurdities
to be able to fill leisure intelligently
is the last product of civilization
and at present
very few people have reached this level
science may set limits to knowledge
but should not set limits to imagination
few people can be happy
unless they hate some other person
nation or creed
even if all the experts agree
they may well be mistaken
[Music]
no nation was ever so virtuous
as each believes itself
and none was ever so wicked
as each believes the other
the most savage controversies
are those about matters to which there
is no good evidence either way
love is wise hatred is foolish
men are born ignorant
not stupid
they are made stupid by education
most people would rather die
than think
and many of them do
one must care about a world one will not
see
the only thing that will help mankind is
cooperation
freedom of opinion can only exist
when the government thinks itself secure
philosophy from the earliest times has
made greater claims
and achieved fewer results
than any other branch of learning
never try to discourage thinking
for you are sure to succeed
extreme hopes are born from extreme
misery
the search for something permanent is
one of the deepest of the instincts
leading men to philosophy
we love our habits more than our income
often more than our life
the biggest loss in a person's life
is the loss of time
the hardest thing in life is to know
which bridge to cross
and which to burn
a man is rational in proportion
as his intelligence informs and controls
his desires
he who does not like loneliness
will never get freedom
a person can be called a fool if he does
not change his mind
belief in god and a future life makes it
possible to go through life with less
stoic courage
than is needed by skeptics
the demand for certainty is one which is
natural to man
but is nevertheless an intellectual vice
the good life is one inspired by love
and guided by knowledge
[Music]
you